supongamos que un objeto se mueve a
razón de 5 metros por segundo esta es su
velocidad en una dimensión cuando es
positiva el objeto se mueve hacia la
derecha y cuando es negativa el objeto
se mueve hacia la izquierda y supongamos
que nos interesa cuál es el cambio del
cambio en la distancia sobre esta delta
significa cambio el cambio en la
distancia sobre el cambio en el tiempo
durante cuatro segundos digamos desde t
igual a 0 a taiwán 4 segundos ese es el
cambio en el tiempo
ese es el intervalo de 4 segundos que
nos interesa bien una manera de ver esto
es una razón una razón de cambio por
definición está dada por el cambio en
una cantidad que nos interesa en este
caso la distancia sobre el cambio en
otra cantidad que nos interesa que en
este caso es el tiempo o también esto
podemos expresar lo como si
multiplicamos ambos lados por el cambio
en el tiempo tenemos que el cambio en la
distancia es igual a la razón de cambio
x
el cambio en el tiempo esto se asemeja a
lo que aprendimos en física elemental
que la distancia es igual a la velocidad
por el tiempo lo hemos obtenido a partir
de la definición de razón de cambio es
decir el cambio en una variable con
respecto al cambio en otra variable así
es que si aplicamos esto a nuestros
datos donde nuestra razón de cambio es 5
metros por segundo el cambio en el
tiempo es igual a 4 segundos obtenemos
que esto es 5 por 4 20 esto es igual a
20 deja de ponerlo con el color adecuado
el color que tengo para el cambio de
distancia esto es igual a 20 y las
unidades son segundos se cancela con
segundos 20 metros durante esos 4
segundos
el objeto avanzó 20 metros hasta aquí no
hay nada nuevo no hay nada
extraordinario lo que quiero hacer ahora
es relacionar esto con el área bajo la
curva de la razón de cambio durante ese
lapso de tiempo hagamos una gráfica este
de aquí es el eje de la razón de cambio
y este de aquí es el eje del tiempo el
tiempo está en segundo la razón
está en metros por segundo pongamos
ahora la escala uno dos tres cuatro
cinco con eso basta ahora la escala para
r uno dos tres cuatro cinco y la razón
de cambio que estamos utilizando para
este ejemplo es un valor constante de
cinco metros por segundo es un valor
constante de cinco metros por segundo
que corresponde a er det y que es lo que
acabamos de hacer aquí hemos
multiplicado el cambio en el tiempo por
la tasa de cambio constante hemos
multiplicado el cambio en el tiempo que
aquí lo tenemos en este eje el cambio en
el tiempo correspondiente a cuatro
segundos que hemos multiplicado por la
tasa de cambio constante
lo hemos multiplicado por esta tasa que
tenemos aquí pero al multiplicar la base
por la altura este rectángulo que
obtengo voy a obtener el área voy a
obtener esta área que está debajo de la
gráfica de la razón de cambio esa área
hemos calculado que es igual a 20
ahora si checamos las unidades
obviamente estamos acostumbrados a que
si es una área deben de ser unidades
cuadradas usualmente tenemos metros
o millas por millas o pies por pies con
lo cual tendríamos 10 cuadrados o metros
cuadrados o millas cuadradas pero si
aquí checamos las unidades de los ejes
tenemos metros sobre segundo
multiplicados por segundos lo cual nos
da metros lo importante aquí es que
hemos obtenido que el valor de esta área
es 20 y vemos entonces que para este
ejemplo simple el área bajo la gráfica
de la función de razón de cambio es
igual al cambio neto en la distancia
durante ese periodo de tiempo donde la
razón de cambio que estamos tomando en
este caso es de la distancia con
respecto al tiempo pero ahora
profundicemos en esto veamos si podemos
captar más el aspecto intuitivo de este
concepto vamos a tomar otra función de
razón de cambios supongamos ahora que la
razón de cambio la va a poner también en
amarillo supongamos que erre dt que la
razón de cambio de la velocidad con
respecto al tiempo está dada por digamos
un metro por segundo cuando te está
entre 0 cuando t es mayor o igual a 0 y
t menor o igual a 2 segundos obviamente
aquí el tiempo sigue está
en segundos r de 32 metros por segundo
cuando t es mayor que 2 segundos como en
la gráfica de esto
de hecho trata de calcular cuál sería el
cambio total en la distancia digamos
durante los primeros 5 segundos así es
que ahora el cambio en la distancia no
es durante los primeros 4 segundos sino
durante los primeros cinco segundos bien
hagamos la gráfica hagamos la gráfica
aquí aquí tenemos entonces este sería un
metro por segundo
este sería dos metros por segundo esto
está entonces en metros por segundo y
este es el eje de la razón de cambio y
este de aquí este de aquí va a ser el
eje del tiempo este aquí va a ser el eje
del tiempo aquí tenemos uno obviamente
no está en la misma escala 345 ahora
como se ve la gráfica de la razón de
cambio la razón de cambio es un metro
por segundo para t entre cero y dos
segundos incluyendo dos segundos y aquí
la razón brinca lo cual no es posible en
realidad pues necesitaríamos una
aceleración infinita que se podría dar
con una
fuerza también infinita o con una masa
muy pequeña en fin no quiero entrar en
detalles pero este brinco que se da aquí
es imposible en el mundo físico tal como
lo conocemos un incremento instantáneo
en la velocidad como el que se presenta
aquí en fin continuemos con esto así es
que después de dos segundos tenemos una
razón de cambio constante una razón de
cambio constante de dos metros por
segundo ahora bien cuál es el cambio
total en la distancia aquí durante los
primeros cinco segundos aquí nos
interesa entonces estos primeros cinco
segundos bien separemos el problema en
dos partes durante los primeros dos
segundos durante los primeros dos
segundos tenemos una razón de cambio
constante de un metro por segundo
así es que dos segundos por un metro por
segundo eso va a ser igual a una
distancia total de dos metros así es que
esta distancia va a ser mejor voy a usar
el color naranja esta distancia va a ser
2 metros y veamos ahora la segunda parte
el cambio aquí en el tiempo es de 3
segundos lo cual vamos a multiplicar por
el valor constante de 2 metros por
segundo eso
6 y si vemos las unidades
en ambos casos vamos a multiplicar
segundos por metros por segundo lo cual
nos da metros
así es que esto es 2 más 6 metros 8
metros espero que con esto ya puedas
apreciar de manera intuitiva que el área
bajo la curva de la razón de cambio te
va a proporcionar el cambio total en la
variable dependiente a la cual se
refiere la razón de cambio en este caso
nuestra razón de cambio en una velocidad
o una razón de cambio de la distancia
con respecto al tiempo el área de esta
razón de cambio de la velocidad de la
razón de cambio de la distancia con
respecto al tiempo durante un cierto
intervalo de tiempo esa área nos va a
proporcionar el cambio neto en la
distancia